en cuántos puntos se intersectan las
gráficas de igual al seno de eta y igual
al coce note tram para am 0 menor o
igual a teta de menor o igual a 2 pi
observa que vamos a incluir al 0 y al 2
pib entre los posibles valores de teta
bueno para hacer esto hice una pequeña
tabla para theta para el concepto de
teta y para el seno de teta la cual
podemos usar junto con el círculo
unitario para obtener una efectiva y
rápida gráfica de las funciones e igual
al seno de teta y de la función y igual
al coseno de teta y luego podemos pensar
en cuántas veces se intersectan y donde
se intersectan así que vamos a iniciar
para ser claros
este es el círculo unitario y aquí tiene
el eje de las equis y este es el eje de
las diez y aquí tenemos el eje teta y
este es el eje y y bueno vamos a
graficar las dos funciones
así que primero pensemos en qué pasa
cuando teta es igual a cero cuando teta
es igual a cero estamos en este punto de
que en el círculo unitario y en qué
coordenadas estamos bueno es la
coordenada 10 así que con base en este
punto cuál es el valor del coche no
detectan cuando teta es igual a cero
bueno el coseno de teta es uno y el seno
de tetas será cero esta es la coordenada
x en el punto de intersección con el
círculo unitario y esta es la coordenada
que bien sigamos veamos qué pasa con pi
medios en primeros estamos ubicados aquí
en qué coordenadas estamos bueno aqui x
es igual a cero y que es igual a uno
ahora con base en esto jose no detectan
va a ser igual a cero y siendo de teta
es igual a uno
es la coordenada de este punto hagamos
lo mismo para ti
ahora nos ubicamos en pi y llegamos a
este punto del círculo unitario en qué
coordenadas estamos
bueno aquí x es igual a menos 1 y que es
igual a cero estamos en el punto menos
10 entonces cuál es el coche no detecta
cuando te desigual a pin bueno es la
coordenada x de aquí que es menos 1 y
seno de tetas era la coordenada jeff la
cual es cero
sigamos ahora vamos a bajar hasta 3
metros vamos a dar esta vuelta hasta
tres primeros aquí en qué coordenadas
estamos bueno aqui x es igual a 0 y ya
es igual a menos 1 entonces el coche no
detecta cuando t t es igual a 3 primeros
es igual a 0 que es la coordenada x de
este punto y el seno de tete es igual a
menos 1 es la coordenada y de este punto
finalmente regresaremos a dos pies
estaremos dando una vuelta completa el
círculo y por lo tanto regresaremos a
este punto de aquí así que las
coordenadas serán las mismas que
teníamos en un ángulo de cero radiales
cuántos el concepto de t tan bueno es
uno y el seno de teta es cero y con
estos valores podemos hacer un boceto de
la gráfica después pensar en donde se
intersectan primero hagamos la gráfica
para la función coseno de teta antes
déjame marcar que aquí es igual a 1 y
acá abajo de igual a menos 1 entonces
cuando te tercero con senos de 31 cuando
te traes pri medios
dt es cero cuando theta espn con 171
cuando te des tres primeros con senos de
70 y por último cuando te traes dos
picos seno de teta es uno y la curva se
va a ver así este es mi mejor intento
para dibujar la puedes ver una curva
suave déjame escribirlo
esta es la gráfica
iguala coseno de teta
ahora hagamos lo mismo para el seno de
teta cuando ted es igual a cero el seno
de eta es igual a cero cuando t t es
igual la pyme dios el seno de teta es
igual a 1 cuando tt es igual a pin el
seno de teta es igual a cero cuando a
teta es igual a tres primeros el seno de
eta es igual a menos uno y por último
cuando teta es igualdad 2 pin el seno de
teta es igual a cero
y la curva se va a ver a algo así
ya está ahora sí enfoquémonos en la
pregunta en cuántos puntos inter secan
las gráficas de ye igual al seno de teta
y de igual al coseno dt está para 0
menor o igual que te está menor igual
que 2 pib incluyendo al 0 y 2 espn bueno
si observamos la gráfica podemos ver dos
puntos de intersección
esto entre 0 y 2 pies ya que estas son
gráficas cíclicas así que seguirán inter
secándose pero en este intervalo sólo se
intersectan dos veces ahora pensemos un
poco en qué valor tomate está en esas
intersecciones porque parece que tomamos
un valor entre 0 y pi medios y otro
valor entre pin y tres primeros para
buscar estos valores observemos el
círculo unitario y pensemos en cuales
podrán ser parece que es pi cuartos así
que vamos a verificarlo
pensemos en qué valores toman estas
funciones en pi cuartos y cuartos es
este ángulo o es el punto final de este
trazo pi cuartos es exactamente lo mismo
que 45 grados así que pensemos en qué
coordenadas estamos cuando tt es igual a
pi cuartos y para esto
hagamos un triángulo rectángulo que
conocemos acerca de él voy a hacerlo más
grande por acá abajo para que lo veamos
mejor
este triángulo rectángulo es un
triángulo que vale la pena
familiarizarse con él sabemos que es un
triángulo rectángulo y que este ángulo
mide 45 grados
ahora cuál es el largo de la hipotenusa
bueno es un círculo unitario tiene un
radio de 1 por lo tanto la longitud de
la hipotenusa es 1
y que sabemos de este ángulo de aquí
bueno sabemos que también debe medir 45
grados porque la suma de todos los
ángulos debe dar 180 grados y si estos
dos ángulos
son los mismos entonces sabemos que
estos dos lados deben medir lo mismo y
ahora podemos usar el teorema de
pitágoras para obtener estos dos lados
usando el teorema de pitágoras y la
conclusión de que estos dos lados son
iguales podremos encontrar la longitud
de los lados bueno si decimos que este
lado tiene una longitud de amd entonces
este otro lado también tiene una
longitud de a y podemos usar el teorema
de pitágoras y decir a cuadrada más a
cuadrada es igual a 1 porque los dos
lados miden lo mismo o dicho de otra
manera 2a cuadrada es igual a 1 o
cuadrada es igual a 1
y si tomamos la raíz cuadrada principal
de ambos lados obtendremos que a es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de un medio que
es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de uno
que es 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de dos
ahora bien podemos racionalizar el
denominador multiplicando por raíz de
dos entre raíz de dos y así obtener que
amd es igual al numerador que tengo uno
por raíz de dos lo cual la raíz de dos y
en el denominador tengo raíz de dos por
raíz de dos lo cual es 2 por lo tanto
este lado es de raíz de 2 entre 2 y este
otro lado vale lo mismo es decir esta
base de equivale a raíz de 2 entre 2 y
esta altura vale lo mismo así que con
base en esto cuáles son las coordenadas
de este punto bueno será raíz de dos
entre dos o más raíces de dos entre dos
x es igual a raíz de 2 entre 2 y que
también es igual a raíz de 2 entre 2 por
lo tanto jose no detecta que es la
coordenada x va a ser raíz de 2 entre 2
y el seno de teta que es la coordenada
james también va a ser raíz de 2 entre 2
por lo tanto puedes ver que en efecto
toman el mismo valor en este punto y por
lo tanto podemos decir que en este punto
ambas gráficas toman el valor de raíz de
2 entre 2 ahora que hay de este punto de
aquí que está entre pi y tres primeros
parece que está justo en medio de ambos
veamos en el círculo unitario este spin
estos tres primeros así que tenemos de
candidato a este valor en medio de ambos
que es pi cuartos más pib lo cual es
bueno y más pi cuartos es lo mismo que
cuatro cuartos más pi cuartos que es 54
así que este ángulo de aquí es cinco
cuartos y vamos a intentar encontrar sus
respectivos valores bueno hay varias
formas de obtenerlos puedes usar un poco
de geometría y decir si este es un
ángulo de 45 grados entonces este ángulo
de aquí también es de 45 grados puedes
decir que el ángulo de referencia ha
visto en grados es también de 45 y
podemos hacer algo similar podemos
dibujar un triángulo rectángulo sabemos
que la hipotenusa es de 1 sabemos que es
un triángulo rectángulo y por lo tanto
este otro ángulo también mide 45 grados
tenemos un triángulo que es muy similar
al otro de hecho son triángulos
congruentes por lo tanto tenemos un
triángulo 45 grados 45 grados 90 grados
cuando la hipotenusa de uno entonces
podemos concluir que la longitud de este
lado también será de raíz de 2 entre 2 y
la longitud de este otro lado también
será de raíz de 2 /
usando la misma lógica que vimos
anteriormente así que con base en esto
cuál es la coordenada de este punto
bueno pensemos en el valor x de este
punto va a raíz de 2 entre 2 en
dirección negativa es decir vamos raíz
de 2 entre 2 a la izquierda del origen
entonces serán menos raíz de 2 entre 2
que pasa con james bueno tenemos que ir
a raíz de 2 entre 2 hacia abajo del
origen por lo tanto también es de menos
raíz de 2 entre 2 jose no de teta es
menos raíz de 2 entre 2 y seno de teta
también es de menos raíz de 2 entre 2
así que puedes ver que en efecto tomamos
de nuevo el mismo valor para las dos
funciones y por lo tanto ya hemos
encontrado ambos valores en donde las
gráficas se intersectan así que hemos
terminado nos vemos del siguiente vídeo